God you Australians are so [ __ ] rude
video game voice acting in the beginning
was very low pain not very serious the
scripting was not very good usually the
directing was awful the loo conversion
sucks but I get the benefits are nice
just the last four or five years it's
become unionized work the pay is much
better than it used to be so obviously
when the paceco went up in the revenue
was generated by the industry the
standards came up dramatically as well
now the directors are better the voice
actors are of higher quality generally
the quality of the games in general is
getting better and better all the time
look at games like World of Warcraft for
instance there are four hundred
characters four hundred different voices
in that game of which I do a few and
that kind of work just keeps coming
around if you're lucky enough to land a
lead role in a game like that you could
be working for years on just a single
game so yeah there's plenty of work out
there it's getting the lead roles that's
tricky
it's a nice day to die for you that is
you remember the old games of the 8-bit
lines but I had a limit of maybe five to
seven seconds that a lion could be
because they could only put so many
files on a cd-rom at the time you know
now it's wide open and there's a lot of
dialogue and and a lot of cutscenes for
them to put it ought to go on so there's
more acting in general in these games
it's not just one liners anymore there's
actual acting I'm gonna rip your eye out
piss on your brain you alien dirtbag
all I have to do is just bring up some
anger from inside and which i find easy
to do I have ex-wives so so I just think
angry I grit my teeth and it just flows
out it's very easy Magic eight bullet
says you did there are other characters
that I find challenging to do for
instance in Guild Wars 2 or in dota
where I'm a Bloodseeker which is a
Hispanic character he's got these tough
voice but he also has a Hispanic accent
he has to maintain the whole time so I
find that a bit of a challenge to stay
in that character for so long I do have
a cookie oh yeah definitely and I've
tried to get other game character roles
where they would all know where
everybody's gonna think of you as Duke
it's like dude I do a lot of voices
they're not little Duke I can put a lot
of voices yeah but we looks like I
tattooed your face with my fist
this sword cuts both ways the fact that
I've been Duke Nukem since 1995 means
that all of those junior high and high
school kids who played Duke Nukem 3d in
the 90s are now game developers they're
the top guys at the software companies
like I'm pretty sure valve hired me
several times for their work because
they're fans they could have had me
record in San Diego or in Los Angeles
but no they insisted on flying me to
Seattle to record their because they're
fans
so while there's that element you know
the fans that will hire me just because
of the association with them playing
Duke there are the others who are afraid
that it's I'm going to be seen as Duke
no matter what what kind of sick mother
picks up wet feces
I think he's a great and viable
character for the next motion picture
superhero anybody million of a she'd go
up my bids he'd be great Duke is it and
now that everything can be done CG
there's no reason to have to cast
somebody who looks like him just animate
the whole thing and as a matter of fact
there could be a whole new genre of film
the r-rated CG movie it should happen
you can show titties and everything
right